well the golden knights back out in the
community spreading some holiday cheer
8 sports kevin martin joins us live in
studio with more details hi kevin
hey kirsten well last week we saw
marc-andre fleury and head coach pete
deboer loading bikes onto a truck that
were donated to families in need this
holiday season today it was the entire
entire flurry family who was out the
community giving back
through the vgk foundation mark andre
his wife veronique and their two oldest
children as well as mark stone and his
fiancee haley
helped load boxes onto a truck for the
holiday cheer box initiative
the custom boxes will be donated to
every woman in the safe nest program
which is an organization committed to
ending domestic violence here
in clark county it's really important
for us for our family to give back
and i think they're never too young to
learn and they've loved to help from the
beginning
my kids and my husband and mark as well
yeah
i think everyone's happy that we're in a
situation where we can help others and
we hope that
these boxes are going to bring some joy
during the holidays for these women
this year people need it more than ever
with a lot of people losing their jobs
and
probably a lot more people being in this
situation
than prettiest years so and it just felt
like in the year everyone needed the
hope and the joy
bernick and haley were blown away by the
outpouring of support from the las vegas
community initially they said they were
hoping to donate around 50 boxes instead
248 total boxes were donated today
just another awesome example of the
golden knights having a positive impact
on our community
denise they never disappoint thanks for
that kevin